nice to see you how are you I'm great
I'm great you look radiant
thank you so much big night for you but
I mean savage X venti gets bigger and
bigger every year this year
Amazon's covering it I mean it's on
Amazon just so I know I mean Savage x is
a brand we've done so much work to get
us the place that we are today yeah and
now that we have people that believe in
us outside of our brand like Amazon
Prime Amazon Prime video they want to
create a whole new platform to come
collaborate with the Savage X platform
and I feel like it's really unique is
special and it makes sense and we are
able to reach new audiences on on both
sides like Amazon Prime has a whole new
audience in the Savage X consumer and
we're creating new consumers through the
Amazon Prime video connection but it
makes sense how much are you involved
with the process and the designing
elements of things oh my god I'm still
involved I want to break but but I am a
control freak so I do everything I see
everything
there's not one step of the way there's
not one lace trim there's not one bra
strop there's not one hardware color
there is not one bolt on a penny that I
do not see and approve not one copy
online that I do not see and approve and
yeah it's a lot of work but it's the
only way that you can preserve a brand
that you start from scratch and here
have a unique opportunity to change
things and I've always been so sincere
with my perspective on this brand but to
see the way that we are perceived in the
lingerie world to see people feeling
included it also puts a different
pressure on me it makes me feel like
now we cannot neglect those consumers
now that consumer is one that's been
neglected before and I'm not gonna let
that happen here yeah well I mean you've
seen celebs like liz' who have embraced
it and you've given her a shout out on
it gosh I love Liz oh she's so badass we
caught up with her just the other day
and she was just raving on and on about
you and said I want to collaborate with
her so is this something that y'all have
talked about no but like I will
collaborate with her on the lights for
this interview like Liz o is so badass
and she's everything that Savage stands
for yeah a confident woman no matter
what size color shape your attitude is
what makes you savage it's the
confidence that you have in yourself and
it's the confidence that you can give
off to people who look like you and feel
like you and those are the people that
identify with the brand are we gonna
hear that confident powerful voice
anyone asking about my album I just knew
it to me give me something well
obviously I'm a confident woman so
whatever I do let's go Nika hopping out
weathers the album perfume lingerie um
makeup or fashion y'all gonna have to
wait maybe I'm so sorry
what about finally Superbowl we're
hearing a lot of rumblings already NFL
season just kicked off is the Super Bowl
halftime show something that you would
be willing to entertain especially now
that jay-z's getting involved with the
entertainment aspects for the late I
should is my first time hearing about
the Super Bowls it's less Super Bowl
really yes it's going on in Miami maybe
JLo Wonder Girl B I still got an album
to finish I have to go Superboy really